Speaker 1: We have a kind of nice way to start
2020 in a very particular sense, among a lot of
bad news. And that's that radical right lunatic.
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene
has been permanently banned from Twitter for
continuing to spread COVID disinformation.
Now there are people acting like we'll get to the
people saying, This is fascism. It's very funny.
We'll get to that. People acting like this was on
a whim with no forethought or basis. This was her
fifth strike. There's an article in the New
York Times Twitter permanently suspends Marjorie
Taylor Greene account social media service says
she violated its COVID misinformation policy.
Twitter suspended her account after she
tweeted on Saturday, falsely about, quote,
extremely high amounts of COVID vaccine
deaths. She included a misleading chart
that pulled information from a government data
database of unverified, raw data called Veirs,
a decade old system that relies on self-reported
cases from patients and health care providers.
Twitter said Miss Green had a fifth strike,
which met her account will not be restored.
The company had issued her a fourth strike in
August, when she falsely posted vaccines were
failing. She had a third strike a month before
that when she treated COVID was not dangerous
and vaccines should not be mandated. Her official
congressional account rep M T G, remains active
because tweets from that account didn't violate
the service's rules. So just to go through it
element by element. I'm showing people the rep
MTG account that one has about 400000 followers.
She has not posted there since December 24th,
where she posted a Christmas message of some kind.
I'll just play a few seconds of it and I will
warn you. Listening to her speak is extremely
triggering and a lot of different ways on
Speaker 4: behalf of myself, my family and
staff. I want to wish all Americans and
especially those in the 14th District.
Speaker 1: And I already I mean, OK, we're done
with that. There are some people reacting to
this in ways that don't don't really make a lot of
sense to me. A lot of people are calling this so.
So there's a lot I don't even know where to start.
First, there's people criticizing and saying that
we need regulation. Twitter shouldn't be allowed
to do this. Why can't businesses have terms of
service that they enforce? And that, I mean,
that's just what it is. There's a lot of confusion
from people who generally say businesses should be
allowed to do whatever they want, as long as it's
not illegal and very few things should be illegal
who are saying businesses shouldn't be allowed to
require vaccines will hold on. Can they require
that you wear a shirt? Yeah. Can they require
that you wear shoes? Yeah. If you don't like
it, can you choose just not to go there? Yeah.
But they can't do vaccines, OK? It doesn't
make sense. That's one hypocrisy. But then
the other one is they're saying there should be
something that the government does to prevent
these businesses from deciding for themselves
what they want to do as long as it's not illegal.
Now there's another aspect to this, which is
people saying this is authoritarian fascism.
Former guest Brian Klaas, he's been on a
couple of times and he was on a few months ago.
He had a really great perspective on
this, which you can find on Twitter.
And he wrote, Whenever Twitter suspends
someone for spreading deadly lies,
someone will call it authoritarianism or fascism.
It's the opposite. It's a free market company
making decisions without government interference
or directives. Fascism is the inverse. Fascism
is extreme state control. And Bryan goes on to say
there are complicated free speech issues around
social media, which we all. I mean, anybody who's
thoughtful agrees with that. But I can assure you,
says Brian, that Twitter couldn't make its
own choices to ban government officials
somewhere like North Korea. They would instantly
be shut down. We don't have fascism here because
Twitter can do this, and at least for now, the
government isn't saying you got to allow Marjorie
Taylor Greene to lie about vaccines or Trump to
do whatever. So let's be consistent. Is it illegal
to do what Twitter is doing? It is not. Well, then
by their definition, if it's not illegal, it's OK
and people can choose to boycott theirs. Many
of you might remember or know or, you know,
whatever that The David Pakman Show started in
the city. I grew up in Northampton, Massachusetts,
and I still have a lot of friends in Northampton.
And recently there was a hearing held by the
Northampton Board of Health about businesses
requiring vaccines. More and more businesses.
You know, I hear from friends, this business,
that business is requiring vaccines. I have
friends who own businesses in Northampton. They
say we're going to require vaccines of customers,
and they had this hearing via Zoom. And, you know,
people could comment on Facebook and elsewhere.
And you have all these people making
conflicting and different arguments like you
about this is the worst decision ever. This
is this is authoritarian. This is not this is
fascism. This is all these different things. Break
it down element by element. Is it illegal for a
business to require proof of vaccines? I don't
even care about does it do anything? I've said
at this point, this thing is so contagious
that the vaccines primarily are protecting
people from serious illness, hospitalization and
death. It's still the cat is out of the bag. This
thing is clearly going to burn its way through
whether there's a vaccine requirement at a local
restaurant or not. But is it illegal to require
vaccines? No. OK, so now we're just in the realm
of opinion. You don't like businesses that require
vaccination, then don't go to them. It's really
that simple. Marjorie Taylor Greene knew what the
rules were at this point. She chose to break them.
It's her fault. She should be banned. That's
it. Officials don't get a special allowance to
spread disinformation about a public health
crisis because their elected officials.
She was elected by Georgia Trumpists to
represent them. It doesn't mean that you
get a national platform or global platform to
tell lies that violate the policy of Twitter.
Is Twitter discriminating against people on the
basis of race when they do these things? No.
Are they discriminating on the basis of national
origin? No. If you don't like it, you don't have
to use Twitter. That's fundamentally what it
is, and this really does matter. And what I mean
by that is when Trump was banned from Twitter,
Mango Mousse and Mussolini the tangerine terror.
You guys remember the guy the amount in general
of hate speech went down. The amount of people
weren't then re amplifying the stuff Trump was
putting out there. So this works and it's legal.
If you don't like it, that's a different story.
And if you want to propose regulation of Twitter
of some kind. I'm glad to discuss it. But then
we have to be able to say we should be regularly
regulating all sorts of different businesses
that right wingers always say let them do
whatever they want, as long as it's not illegal
as of right now. I want to hear from you guys.
We'll post more about this on our Instagram.
You can find us there at David Pakman show.